[Musique]
c'était il y a un peu plus de 45 ans
pierre elliott trudeau devenait le
premier dirigeant canadiens à visiter
officiellement la chine une visite
historique chez mao tsé toung
le leader chinois boudé par l'occident
et qui est aux commandes d'un pays qui
n'est alors qu'un petit joueur sur la
scène mondiale
en ce qui concerne la politique
étrangère et en particulier relations
avec le canada
autant que je puisse penser ça va
continuer en progressant la continuité
fut assurée avec brian mulroney qui s'y
rendit en 1986 mais à 1989 la brutale
répression sur la place tiananmen
encouragés par le pouvoir chinois et
dénoncé par le premier ministre
conservateur
je trouve absolument horrible l'idée que
l'on puisse se féliciter qui que ce soit
dans le mérite c'est d'avoir tiré sur
des gens gino ste sous jean chrétien les
relations avec la chine vont pourtant
prendre un virage celui de la croissance
économique et des échanges commerciaux
intensifiée même si à l'époque il
n'hésite pas à serrer la main de l'un
des responsables de la répression de
tiananmen
jean chrétien va soulever avec fermeté
la question des droits de la personne en
chine
la liberté d'expression la liberté de
presse la liberté de religion
persuadé que faire des affaires avec la
chine favorisera la démocratisation
le premier ministre chrétien va alors
organiser la plus importante mission
économique en 2001 la chine deviendra
alors le deuxième partenaire commercial
du canada
quelques années plus tard l' empire du
milieu va bouder le canada parce que
stephen harper lui va découvrir que pour
gagner une partie stratégique avec la
chine
il ne faut pas tout miser sur la défense
des droits de la personne
stephen harper se rendra à l'évidence
les affaires avant tout avec un géant
qui ne cesse de grandir
la diplomatie passera donc par les
pandas le symbole des bonnes relations
avec la chine
bref tout a bien changé depuis 1973 et
le deuxième trou d'eau au pouvoir au
canada doit continuer de composer
avec un pays plus que jamais
incontournable ici frédéric arnould
radio canada montréal